popularity is no mark of quality so um a
more generalized movie list I'd have I
actually have a number of things sort of
in a similar vein to this that I'm
working on this is just the one I got to
first so I'm gonna talk about ten movies
that I like that nobody saw now they'd
like some criteria when I say that like
what I what I did to sort of qualify or
disqualify a movie from being on this
list was to look at its box office
returns and if it was a notable tanking
especial again and like I don't think
any of these are particularly high
budget so like if they didn't make their
money back then really nobody saw them
um that's sort of my basic thing now I
was sort of judging that off a box
office some of these may have developed
a little bit more of a cult following in
the year since it was in the theaters
things like that I didn't take that into
account I just went by what was the
initial impact and in pretty much every
case it was little to nothing now not
all of these were even wide releases but
you know what that was that I didn't
feel like putting that kind of caveat on
it now these last other thing this list
is in absolutely no particular order
I've got ten so it is a top ten but it's
not ranked so starting with shoot them
up I have so much fun with this movie if
you have not seen it or not familiar
with it and actually I had just occurred
to me you probably won't be with most of
these so I need to explain all of these
as I go shoot him up was a film starving
Clive Owen and Paul Giamatti which is
basically a Looney Tunes cartoon done in
live-action with guns and I know that
sounds weird I don't mean that quite as
literal as as it sounds but what I mean
is like forget physics physics are
immediately out the window the things
done with it like a guy shooting a gun
at like a merry-go-round and hitting it
at the right angle starts the
merry-go-round spinning
and he shoots it a few more times to
make it spin faster and faster faster
it's that level of ridiculousness I mean
that's not even close to the most
ridiculous that these that this stuff
happens basically what this film is is
the people who made it sat down and
thought what's the most ridiculous cool
stuff that we would like to see done in
a gunfight in a movie that no one else
will ever do because they'll go that's
not believable and they poured it all
into this movie and the performances are
actually a lot of fun too Clive Owen you
know doing the very stoic thing but it
is set up very deliberately a Clive Owen
is Bugs Bunny and Paul Giamatti is sort
of the head of the bad guys as Elmer
Fudd they are that is made really
explicit in a few ways and they do kind
of have that dynamic of constant thinks
he's got him
you know outwits him sort of thing going
on with all this insane gun fighting and
Paul Giamatti is so much fun like all of
it is great there are like a couple of
tiny lulls in it but man if you are if
you are prepared to have a gunfight that
has no intention of being anything close
to realistic yeah this this is something
that you should see a next one from
there it's a movie that I've actually
talked about before and I may at some
point have to do a more in-depth
explanation of what I like about it but
that is repo the Genetic Opera this is a
fairly recent I mean I say fairly it's I
guess it's about a decade old now but
it's not all that old you know movie
musical that did not do very well at all
and I can see why here's the thing that
some of these like I don't get why they
weren't successful other than like not
you know it was marketed improperly I
think something like shoot him up maybe
that was the case or maybe just the
world wasn't ready for guys we were kind
of in the middle of the more gritty
down-to-earth stuff I think he came out
same your Dark Knight did but was
something like this with something like
repo I can look at it and go yeah I get
why most people look at this and go I
don't know what this is but I don't like
it
so what repo is is it is as I said it's
a rock opera it is set in a dystopian
future in which people are able to
replace any and all organs in fact it's
so easy that they do it for
completely cosmetic and know medically
necessitated reason whatsoever but they
go into debt in order to do this and and
these organs are basically on loan if
you miss a payment
it gets repossessed if that sounds
familiar yes that is the exact same plot
of the movie repo men which came out
around the same time and is not a
musical and I actually still have a got
no I've seen but this movie has anthony
Stewart head
it has oh I've lost I've also now I've
lost names of the actors but it's got
one of the the young actors from Spy
Kids you know in her late teens
singing Alexa Vega there we go singing
her heart out throughout the whole thing
with Sarah Brightman Christine from the
original Broadway production of Phantom
of the Opera she's in this and she's
awesome the singing is great the songs
are insane with the aim what I like
about this particularly is when I say
rock opera emphasis is on the Opera part
this is operatic in the sense of nobody
can just feel something or think
something they have to belt it to the
heavens like the gods themselves have to
hear how they feel about this that's the
way this story is told is it ridiculous
you bet your butt it is but man do I
really like it it is insane and it is
rocking and it is gory and it is not for
everybody but man do I love it okay so
next up from there is a dark comedy that
I feel like this is something more
people found after it had its limited
theatre run buckle see and that is
World's Greatest Dad
now I actually debated putting either
this or or let sleeping dogs lie or
maybe it's just let dogs like whatever
Bobcat Goldthwait who wrote and directed
this whatever his previous movie was
prior to this I debated doing either one
of these but I went with this one
and this stars Robin Williams and it's
it basically it is about a father who a
single father who is a you know sort of
a frustrated would-be author he's
getting by you know teaching to pay the
bills I think it's a
high school level and he has the world's
worst son his kid is a terrible human
being like on every level he's awful but
sore and the thing is this is not
heartwarming when I say this is a dark
comedy I mean this is dark and I don't
want to say like even sort of the like I
would say if you haven't seen this yet
and it sounds at all appealing check it
out avoid descriptions if you can cuz a
lot of them kind of blow what happens
within about the first half hour I would
say that hits better if you don't know
it's gonna happen but the way things go
what I love about it is it it basically
one of its core one it has a number of
messages going on but one of its core
messages is loving the fact that you
love somebody doesn't make them a good
person because Robin Wayans does love
his son but he's also a terrible
terrible terrible human being and he's
kind of got a deal with that and it's
it's it's really good it's it's like I
said it is very funny it's a really
great performance from Williams and if
you can handle some very raunchy very
dark humor I would say check that one
out all right what do I got next ah yes
let's get into a little bit of somber
sci-fi with never let me go so I feel
like this is one that more people well
more people should have seen anyways but
I feel like if people had warm to Andrew
Garfield's spider-man more this is the
kind of thing that would have been the
oh this was that where he was really
good and that other thing before we all
knew from spider-man but that didn't
work out um so this didn't get the
rediscovery I kind of would have would
have hoped again we're dealing with kind
of a near-future setting like not
dealing with the extreme technology
technology basically is what it is but
we are dealing with people being we are
dealing with people being raised for
their organs to be harvested and the
thing is
it's not as horrific as you would think
based of that like basically the
description you'd think it'd be
something like repo where it's gory and
off but it's not because what it is is
it's an examination of these people and
it's just looking at their lives in the
tragedy of their lives it doesn't go
down the body horror or the action route
that it very easily could have with with
a different director and with a
different mindset it is a very low-key
emotionally driven contemplative
relationship based story with a with a
science fiction gimmick I hesitate to
call it a science fiction movie because
the science really just enables the
specific brand of character and
relationship drama that it's doing but
it's not you know it's not it lacks the
trappings that you normally see in a
sci-fi film so if you have an enjoyment
of of these sorts of deep character
dives I I would recommend it it is it is
somber it is bittersweet
it is melancholy in it is beautiful what
is that for so far yeah so we're up to
five and another one that's actually
kind of in a similar vein in that it is
also contemplative in melancholy and
sci-fi but the sci-fi is a bit more a
friend Center and that is the fountain
Darren Aronofsky's the fountain and this
is one of the ones that always strikes
me as odd that it was not as well
received as I would have thought like it
for me it's very much in keeping with
line with the movies well the movies
he's made sense and the movies he made
before you know like pie or requiem for
a dream yet for some reason it didn't go
down well for people but what we've got
here is we've got a three timeline
romance story oh I say romance it feels
somewhat one-sided because it's largely
about this man's obsession the man
played by Hugh Jackman in these three
different are incarnations one is sort
of the Spanish conquistador sort of era
one modern day where he's a doctor and
one set in the set in the far future and
all three times I obsessing over the
distance between him and this woman or
how to attain this woman or the fact
that he lost this woman it varies
depending on the time line and the woman
played by Rachel Weisz and it's it's sad
it's gorgeous I mean it is a visually I
think this might have been the first
movie I bottom blu-ray like it is a
stunningly gorgeous film I think maybe
what throws people off about it is it
doesn't explain itself very much it just
kind of shows you what's going on but it
doesn't explain what it is you're seeing
and I guess to a certain degree and not
in terms of theming at all but in terms
of storytelling approach it bears a
certain resemblance to 2001 a Space
Odyssey in that way for me at least the
difference is I feel like there are
enough pieces in play that you do
understand that you can make the
connections now they may not exactly be
the connections that Darren Aronofsky
had in terms of the narrative that he
was building but I feel like if you're
willing to put in the work you can come
up with a workable theory of exactly how
this works and is playing out and I
think Hugh Jackman really sells it
exceptionally well I think the
visualization of the future setting and
the way that space travel is done with
this sort of energy bubble is really
cool I just I think this is a gorgeous
movie and I found it quite touching
so that's halfway through where are we
now ah yes the the one good movie that
Tarsem Singh had in him that's the fall
the fall is another slightly odd but
visually stunning movie I mean and and
that's the one thing tarsem say he did
the cell he and he was best known for
sort of music videos prior to that and
it like you can't take away the fact
that the man has an amazing eye his
storytelling instincts not so much but
the fall happens to be about stuff that
I almost always tend to connect with
it's a story about stories and it deals
with a guy
I who is a stuntman in like the silent
film era who is injured in a stunt gone
wrong and now he's laid up in this
hospital and he starts having these
conversations with this much younger
girl and what I say much younger I mean
like she I don't know six or something
and he starts telling her a story that
he is making up but is obviously very
heavily influenced by the kind of movies
he takes part in and sort of some issues
that he's going through with his own
life and her eagerness to hear the story
and what that does to him his
frustration with his own life and with
wanting to sort of wrenched control of
his own life story and how that starts
to bleed into his interactions with her
and then the the visualization of any
and all of this is just astounding I
think that the performances are great
and the connection made between those
two actors is really great and that and
that's what makes it more than just a
pretty piece is the emotions are really
well sold by those actors and I think
there's a stunning film so where are we
now
ah yes robot in Frank Frank Langella is
an actor who I discovered in a very bad
movie and that is Masters of the
Universe and I love him as Skeletor and
I love him in literally everything I've
ever seen him in he is always stuck in
my head and this is one of the the the
thing is he has a tendency to go be like
Shakespearean big I mean that's kind of
the quality he brought to Skeletor
but what's on display here is much more
Loki is much more restrained but no less
powerful like if you think of Frank
Langella as an over-the-top actor you
need to see this film because it's and
then and this is actually it's funny I
didn't think about the order that I had
put these in but I accidentally ended up
grouping together things with similar
themes so this will come up again a bit
but it's kind of a meditation on Aging
and on the ways in which one loses their
own agency
as they get older and they lose certain
faculties and all the things that they
need in order to take care of themselves
and so you have an again a near future
setting what does it need me in near
future movies on this list huh so it's
not that far out technology wise but
Frank this elderly man you know who is
an X thief like professionally he is
given a robot that is meant to help him
and it's funny in a way I think this
came out before big hero six did in some
ways it feels like almost a test run for
baymax because there's there's no like
and the robot is learning and it gains a
soul and sent against now there's none
of that
it's a machine it's programmed but
within the boundaries of its program
there is still a connection and a
relationship to be had between the robot
and Frank and watching that relationship
develop seeing where it goes seeing what
it does for Frank both in the positive
and the negative is just really well
done and I again I found quite touching
and now like I said I unintentionally
somehow lumping together theme things um
another movie that I actually have
talked about before I didn't do a proper
review on it but the year that it came
out which I think was 2014 but that year
I put it on my list of best movies of
that year and that is mr. Holmes and
this is this is another sort of
meditation on Aging so this has an
McKellen playing Sherlock Holmes now
before you get too excited by that
description this is not a mystery
solving Sherlock this is a very very old
Sherlock Holmes who has some left of
what he had in terms of his mind in his
mental capabilities but he's not what he
once was and he knows that and him
trying him trying to come to terms with
that and part of that is funneled
through him thinking on and trying to
contemplate what to do about a about a
case that he didn't finish so there is a
little bit
mr. aspect but that's incidental that's
sort of how he's one of the ways he's
funneling his energies but ultimately
it's just about growing old and not
being capable of being who you were and
sort of in a way living in the shadow of
yourself and this came out excuse me
this came out the same year my
grandfather died he and he'd had he'd
had dementia
he had a dwindling mental capacity as he
got older he didn't have Alzheimer's so
like he never didn't recognize me he
always knew who I was he was always
excited to see me but he couldn't he
couldn't process new information very
well anymore and so maybe part of my
connection to this is the timing with
which I saw it but I think it captures
the frustration of somebody going
through that towards the end of their
life in a very real and moving way well
lighten things up slightly with the next
one we're almost done and this one is
another one that again I get it
it's really weird and it's got a weird
vibe and it's got a weirder look and
that's Mirrormask this was pitched in
some ways as like a spiritual successor
to labyrinth which I don't think is a
great comparison yes it involves the the
Jim Henson company but it doesn't
involve that aesthetic it's not dealing
with physical puppets it's a very
surreal largely computer animated some
2d animation or like hybrid kind of
stuff going on it's a story about a
teenage girl who actually isn't the
circus sort of wanting to escape from
that and she finds herself in this
fantastical world and now has to find a
way out of it
and there are the usual sort of
parallels to people in her real life so
like she meets a very clear
you know one-to-one analog for her
father and her mother and despite having
a very Allison wonder laying kind of
setup it's got that sort of one layer
detached it feels almost like like
looking at a diorama like it's hard to
feel like you're part of it you are just
watching him for me though that's part
of the appeal I think that's a lot has a
lot to do with the the visitor the
visual sensibilities of Dave McKean who
was the director on it Neil Gaiman
helped write it and again it does touch
on things like the importance of stories
and the value of stories which which I
always appreciate and there's just
something about the the pace and the
progression of everything that clicks
really well for me here it's hard for me
to put my finger on why I like this so
much but it just works and I get why it
doesn't work for a lot of people but for
me yeah it just works all right last one
and this one I I think part of the
reason I I put this one last is that
I've mentioned before I'm not big on
romantic movies especially anything that
could be described as a romantic comedy
which this kind of is but also kind of
really isn't and that's donjon now this
is a film starring and also directed by
Joseph gordon-levitt and it's about a
guy who is basically very into gym
working out and porn that's all that
he's about and he you know he's all
about hitting the gym and watching porn
and masturbating that's his entire
routine and he gets involved with a girl
played by Scarlett Johansson we sort of
see that relationship go on but then
like his life doesn't add up it doesn't
come in two parts
and there's a lot of very you know very
blue humor I'm going on this it's fairly
rocky and there's some very funny
moments involved in that but ultimately
by the time it ends and I don't want to
explain how but it became by the time it
was done one of the most bizarre
but sincerely romantic films I'd ever
seen and I wasn't expecting it to happen
from this film and I definitely wasn't
expecting it the way that it happened
and really to say much more than that
will be spoiler but the performances are
all great Joseph gordon-levitt did a
great job and I think it's fantastic so
that's ten movies that I love that
basically nobody saw it
do you have movies that you like that
we're not well seen pretty sure we've
all got a few movies that we like that
it seemed like nobody else ever saw what
was it for you something you saw as a
kid nostalgic favorite something you see
more recently if I got under viewed
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it hole
punch is something you can do down there
besides cuz there's buttons and links
and there's merch and there's my peel
box and there's the link to the patreon
which is immensely helpful and
supportive thank you all who currently
contribute but you know check all that
there's other stuff besides in if you
don't want to look at any of that that's
okay cuz at the end of the day you're
the council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]